et la semaine dernière c'est vrai qu'on
a eu Pascal euh qui était là qui est un
ancien candidat de Koh-Lanta et c'est
vrai que bon apparemment il partira pas
en vacances avec Denis Brogniart je
crois que c'est pas prévu pour cette
année
c'est vrai que c'était fou alors on a vu
derrière derrière c'est vrai que bon
tout le monde a communiqué il y a eu des
anciens candidats qui ont dit voilà
Denis Brogniart qui est formidable plus
de limognard manger du manioc le bon
Denis Brogniart voilà comme c'est vrai
et mais la vie quoi et c'est vrai que ça
a été un changement de l'impression que
ça a été un peu panique à bord oui oui
moi justement je voulais vous entendre
là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous pensez
justement du cas de ni Brogniart est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est le maillot de
nébrunner je trouve que c'est pas le bon
terme alors est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est le maillon faible il a quand même
été il y a quelques semaines dans une
sorte de tourbillon médiatique avec des
il a été il a été dans un temps bien et
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous alors
moi je peux en parler de temps plus que
ça fait 7 ans que je collabore avec lui
que je suis patronne d'une société avec
lequel il collabore que moi je n'ai
jamais assisté à à des énervements oui
il est soupeé alors déjà unisexe il peut
être soupe avec un mec une gonzesse ça
n'a franchement voilà il est extrêmement
exigeant c'est vrai et que
dans des conditions de direct parce que
les deux événements se sont passés dans
des conditions directes sur TF1
face à une collaboratrice c'était pas un
lien de subordination voilà il est sous
pollué donc en effet il s'est énervé je
trouve ça déjà admirable qui se soit
quand même excusé tout de suite c'est
normal non non mais tu sais très bien
qu'il y en a qui le font pas et
sincèrement ça s'est passé
deux fois dans une carrière de 30 ans
voilà je trouve que quand on parle de
harcèlement moi je suis allé voir la
diffusion du harcèlement le harcèlement
c'est une répétition de pression
physique et psychologique en
l'occurrence
de tennis à Mathieu Delon
alors que les deux jeunes femmes
du coup je le conteste et et je pense
que Denis n'était pas conscient en effet
de l'État peut-être de fragilité dans
lesquels étaient la jeune femme du 14
juillet si j'ai bien compris et
Charlotte Moura qu'un gros caractère je
pense qu'elle n'était pas fragile mais
elle a été choquée donc quoi qu'il en
soit ça pour le coup c'est évidemment
c'est pas acceptable néanmoins on est ni
dans du harcèlement ni enfin ni dans un
lien de subordination il a pas demandé
leur tête à aucun moment il a été
question de ça Charlotte n'aimera elle
était là la semaine suivante à ses côtés
mais ça je sais qu'il y a pas de
conférence de rédaction sur cette
émission il y a une conférence de
rédaction sur auto-moto en effet sur
auto-moto mais pas sur cette émission
dans quel monde
mois sur l'émission sur la Coupe du
monde donc elle ment et bah
regarde
ton masque
on n'a pas du tout parlé de Koh-Lanta en
l'occurrence par rapport à Denis
Brogniart ou de choses comme ça moi je
vous dis en effet quelques fois un peu
soupe au lait et voilà mais sincèrement
il y a jamais eu de débordement alors
vous imaginez moi Patrick femme face à
un débordement sur une femme c'est pas
c'est pas acceptable donc voilà sur
il va être chiant lui non non TF1 la
convoqué quand même pour savoir ce qui
s'est exactement passé est-ce que vous
vous l'avez fait et ce que vous songez
vu toutes les turbulences à le remplacer
alors aux deux questions non pourquoi
parce que moi je pense beaucoup je
convoque quelqu'un quand il y a un
problème sur mes tournages
donc
sincèrement si maintenant je veux pas
minimiser leur ressenti on est bien
d'accord en revanche voilà on redescend
d'un état on a fait beaucoup de bruit
là-dessus on parle de 30 secondes 2 fois
30 secondes d'un mec est en direct qui
monte un peu dans les tours parce que il
y a une histoire d'exigence et de
problèmes donc je sais plutôt une grosse
engueulade entre collègues et je pense
qu'on a tous ça et moi ça m'est déjà
arrivé de gueuler et je pense que enfin
je pense que ça nous c'est tous arrivé
non mais juste est-ce qu'il y a un
moment est-ce qu'à un moment TF1 ouais
quand même non mais ça c'est parce que
c'est tentant
un peu attaqué évidemment c'est tentant
et c'est un peu ça qui est difficile et
je moi j'ai toujours beaucoup de
tendresse pour les gens qui sont un peu
en bas parce que
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas du tout non puis alors franchement
enfin l'image de données c'est marrant
parce qu'on a fait le musée grève qui
lui eux ont fait des études c'est ce que
je ne savais pas de popularité qu'avant
que quelqu'un rentre dans le musée
Grévin ça je savais pas et tous les
curseurs étaient ouverts
je pense qu'il faut considérer comme
deux fois 30 secondes et ça a pas été
une erreur de le mettre sur un autre jeu
d'aventure qu'il a fait sur TF1 bah oui
ça c'est énorme connerie
puisque c'est de l'animateur phare de
l'émission
et je me suis largement exprimée
là-dessus chez moi je pensais être une
connerie même pour TF1 parce que bien
sûr rien d'autre animateur on aurait
compris ces deux programmes différents
donc il est aussi dans des obligations
on lui dit voilà tu vas
Alexia je te dis la vérité c'est parce
que Alexia je le dis c'est un amour
voilà Alexia elle fait son taf elle s'en
fout elle avance je la connais par cœur
elle s'en fout de ses conneries mais
Alexia si elle avait vraiment été
chiante et si ça a été un mec plus
chiant il l'aurait dit il aurait dit
écoute Koh-Lanta c'est la marque phare
de TF1 c'est ta marque phare c'est la
marque avec laquelle tu t'es fait
connaître c'est ta marque que Denis
Brognard dans la tête des gens c'est
Koh-Lanta tu vas aller faire le guignol
sur un autre jeu écoute-moi bien tu vas
rien faire du tout parce que sinon
Koh-Lanta on va essayer on va te
remplacer moi ça aurait été mes terres
après voilà chacun fait comme il veut
même pas eu besoin de faire ça le
programme c'est mort
la moitié que ça va mieux avec Arthur on
s'entend mieux donc je m'en fous en plus
tu vois que voilà que ça soit Z ou autre
chose c'est même pour eux pour TF1 je
trouve que c'est con parce qu'il aurait
fallu lancer un autre animateur parce
que je trouve que c'est c'était un peu
tu vois ça a été c'est même pour la
marque c'était un peu chiant je pense
voilà c'est bon